قرر معتوه سرقة سيارة الدورية الخاصة به
مما أدى في النهاية إلى
مطاردتنا
لهم ثم وقع
حادث مأساوي حيث
قُتل شخصان بسبب ذلك
المعتوه الفظ والمستعد للدفاع عن
نائبه، تُظهر لقطات كاميرا الجسم النائب وهو
يستجيب لمكالمة سرقة  في
ساحة التسوق على طريق East State Road 40
بعد ظهر يوم الخميس، صعدت امرأة ودحرجت
النافذة الجانبية للركاب
وقالت إنهما يتحدثان خلف سيارة الدورية ذات الدفع الرباعي
في ثوانٍ، أدرك أنها زحفت
في النافذة الجانبية المفتوحة للراكب
وفي توقف السائقين توقف توقف توقف
لقد ركبت سيارتي للتو لتنزل من مستجيب
آخر، وطاردها نائب في
اللحظة التي فعلت فيها أنها كانت تشكل تهديدًا
لحياة الإنسان
لمجرد ركوبها تلك
السيارة، يقول الشريف إن وكالته كانت
ملزمة بمطاردة سيارة الدفع الرباعي هذه لأنهم كانوا
يعرفون  ما كان متاحًا لها
في متناول يدها كان هناك بندقية طويلة
هناك، يقول مكتب الشريف إنها
كانت كيندرا بون البالغة من العمر 33 عامًا في السيارة الرياضية متعددة الاستخدامات التي كانت
تسرع بسرعة تزيد عن 100 ميل في الساعة،
وفقدت السيطرة في النهاية واصطدمت
رأسًا بشاحنة صغيرة مما أسفر عن مقتل شخصين.
في السبعينيات من عمرها من ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية،
هذا هو تاريخها الإجرامي، شريف
وودز يعرض لفافة من الورق مع
اعتقالاتها السابقة، ويقول إنه نادرًا ما
ينتهي الأمر بالسجن أو السجن إذا
كان هذا الشخص في السجن،
فلن يكون لدي شخصين بريئين ميتين
يصر الشريف أيضًا على أن كل ما
حدث كان بسبب رفض بون
التحدث عن الإجراءات أو السياسات مع
وكالته، هذا المعتوه سرق
سيارة شرطة وقتل شخصين، ما هي
سياساتي، ما هي الإجراءات،
لا تعني شيئًا، لم نرتكب أي خطأ، نائبي لم
يرتكب أي خطأ  في مقاطعة ماران، ديف
مكدانيل دبليو محطة فرعية للأخبار